la macro ni un qui commence on l'aura
compris à organiser ses forces en vue de
la présidentielle alors que le principal
intéressé reste toujours muet sur ses
intentions parmi les interrogations sa
participation à d'éventuelles débat télé
entre candidats dès le premier tour un
enjeu tactique de taille katia pique
nique
emmanuel macron acceptera-t-il de
débattre avec ses adversaires à la
présidentielle en 2017 les candidats au
premier tour avait participé à un débat
le 20 mars sur tf1 ils étaient cinq et
le 4 avril sur bfm tv et ses news 11 à
une différence près le président sortant
françois hollande ne participait pas car
il n'était pas entré dans la course tout
d'abord il faudrait qu emmanuel macron
se déclare ou non candidat alors qu'il
ne reste qu'un peu plus de deux mois
avant le premier tour si la lumière
n'est toujours pas faite sur ses
intentions le message est déjà passé au
sujet d'une éventuelle participation au
débat le figaro cite plusieurs sources
parmi les patrons de presse qui estime
qu'un modèle macron n'a pas très envie
de se prêter au jeu puis dimanche ce fut
au tour de gabrielle attal le porte
parole du gouvernement de préciser le
président a toujours montré son intérêt
pour la confrontation d'idées mais à
quoi ressemblerait ce débat de premier
tour
douze candidats cherchant pendant 1h50
leurs moments avec le président qui
aurait dix minutes pour leur répondre je
suis sceptique face à un tel format qui
montrerait surtout un manque d'exigence
démocratique
les français le savent on peut débattre
de bien des manières en 2022 débattre
tout seul dans son coin sans se
confronter à ses rivaux voilà un concept
bien novateur peut-être avec un live sur
zoom des story sondage sur instagram ou
encore un nouveau grand débat en région
cette réticence n'est bien sûr pas du
goût des candidats qui disent être
proche de l'obtention des 500 signatures
ou les avantages obtenus c'est le cas de
valérie pécresse la candidate des
républicains qui demandent
solennellement je cite un débat il doit
rendre compte de son bilan qui est
calamiteux de l'état de notre école de
l'état de notre hôpital de l'état de
notre justice de la violence qui monte
dans les rues de l'immigration qui est
un contrôle et la démocratie moderne
aujourd'hui c'est accepter le débat
c'est accepter la contradiction on a une
présidence du mépris une présidence
hautaine distante et solitaire et le
président du rassemblement national
jordan bardella il va aussi de son
exhortation nous appelons emmanuel
macron à sortir de l'ambiguïté et à se
déclarer comme candidat qu'ils aient le
courage de descendre dans l'arène qu'ils
acceptent le débat et répondre de son
bilan quant à jean luc mélenchon le
leader insoumis il s'est emporté chez
cyril hanouna au sujet de l'impossible
débat macro incline pagaille dans ce
pays et personne ne pourra lui demander
des comptes florian philippot le
candidat des patriotes nicolas dupont
aignan celui de debout la france ont
aussi demandé par voie de tweets une
participation aux débats il faut tout de
même noter que certains candidats ne
veulent pas débattre entre eux par
exemple marine le pen refuse de discuter
avec eric zemmour yannick jadot ne veut
pas de confrontation avec anne hidalgo
jean luc mélenchon quant à lui ne
souhaite pas échangé avec je cite les
nains de la gauche difficile de
rassembler ces personnalités
antagonistes sans qu'elle ne s'étripe ou
concentre toute leur vindicte sur
emmanuel macron il faut rappeler
qu'aucun président en exercice n'a pour
le moment participer à cet exercice
télévisé au premier tour jacques chirac
ou nicolas sarkozy avait ainsi décliné
en leur temps mais l'époque a changé
alors de l'importance des réseaux
sociaux et après deux ans de pandémie
qui ont brouillé les cartes un tel débat
remettrait les compteurs à zéro il ne
serait pas qu'une aubaine pour les
candidats mais aussi pour les français
qui le demandent le locataire de
l'élysée consentira-t-il à quitter les
ordres de son bureau pour affronter ses
rivaux qui rêvent d'en découdre
réponse dans quelques semaines et à
gauche